laser vision throat surgery to end the
zombie apocalypse believe it or not
that's not even the weirdest way of
fight between Superman and Black Adam
has ended
in the comics Black Adam is not a sworn
enemy of Superman regardless of the
Rock's desire to see these powerhouses
trade blows on the big screen they don't
actually have an official rivalry with
one another in DC lore Black Adam
originally known as teth Adam was called
The Mighty atom after the wizard Shazam
bestowed on him the ability to say
Shazam and gain all his power
unfortunately Black Adam abused this
power using it for selfish gain and then
for evil because of this the wizard
imprisoned Black Adam vowing to wait for
the right person to come along and be
his next champion
I was a slave until I died
then I was reborn of God
centuries later Billy Batson has chosen
to wield the power of Shazam because of
this Black Adam returns hoping to kill
the boy and claim his powers in some
versions Black Adam also kills both of
Billy's parents though in the most
recent origin he simply wants the full
Shazam power set to himself thus Black
Adam is traditionally the arch nemesis
of DC's Captain Marvel the hero more
commonly known today as Shazam and not
to be confused with Marvel's Carol
Danvers because of his ties to the magic
side of the DCU Black Adam rarely
engages with Superman who is vulnerable
to Magic generally Black Adam and Shazam
are more closely involved with the
Justice Society of America and as comic
book readers and moviegoers alike will
know Superman is a part of the Justice
League a totally different superhero
team as a result they mostly stick to
their own corners of the DC Universe
however these two big hitters have still
crossed paths on occasion
Black Adam first battled Superman in
issue number 58 of all new collector's
edition a comic series that often pitted
DC characters who might not normally
fight against each other during this
period in comic book history Superman
and the Justice League stories took
place in a world called Earth one while
the Marvel family and Black Adam existed
in a world called Earth s the S is
surprisingly not for Shazam in this
issue the first ever crossover between
the Man of Steel and shazam's Fallen
Champion took place it all unfolds after
Black Adam uses a spell to disguise
himself as Captain Marvel and begins
destroying Metropolis while posing as
Earth's Mightiest mortal Superman tries
to stop the fake Captain Marvel who then
uses red Sun radiation a weakness of
Superman's to disarm and defeat the Man
of Steel eventually the real Captain
Marvel returns to earth 1 but Superman
believing that his former Ally has gone
Rogue attacks and nearly kills Captain
Marvel seeing this take place the wizard
Shazam explains the situation to
Superman who apologizes to Captain
Marvel for the Beatdown Black Adam at
the behest of Martian sorcerer and
scientist carmong the evil plans to
merge the Two Worlds together in what
could have proven to be a cataclysmic
event thankfully the duo of Superman and
Captain Marvel thwart carmong's plan and
send Black Adam back to Earth s together
all in a day's work
a few years later Black Adam returned to
the main DC Universe of Earth 1 and DC
Comics presents number 49 which hit
shelves in September 1982 in this issue
of the famed DC team-up series Black
Adam comes to Earth 1 and attempts to
conquer the world liking his chances
because it's a world without Captain
Marvel he also hopes to defeat Superman
again in the process but he knows it
won't be a simple task as such Black
Adam decides to hold Earth one's Billy
Batson hostage and use him to keep
Superman from thwarting another one of
his plots
now I kneel before no one though
Superman at first tries to talk Black
Adam down and handle things
diplomatically the super villain refuses
to yield instead of listening to reason
he engages in an exceedingly dangerous
battle with the Man of Steel like before
Black Adam begins to overpower Superman
due to the magical nature of his
abilities but the Kryptonian has a trick
up his sleeve Superman manages to rescue
Billy from Adam's grasp and uses him to
bring the Billy Batson of Earth s to
Earth one so he can join the fight after
a big battle involving Superman Captain
Marvel and Black Adam the super villain
is finally defeated how it's pretty
simple really Earth one's Billy Batson
tricks him into saying Shazam stripping
him of his powers and returning him to
human form Captain Marvel then uses the
few brief seconds afterward to knock out
teth Adam and keep him from transforming
into Black Adam again and with that he
says goodbye to Superman and they return
to their own world
in the years that followed the Man of
Steel and black Adam's second bout Earth
1 and Earth s along with numerous other
worlds were merged into a single new
Earth that featured Superman Captain
Marvel and all of their respective foes
Black Adam was reformed into something
of an anti-hero and even joined Captain
Marvel and the ranks of the Justice
Society of America at one stage this
wouldn't last though and Black Adam
eventually Associated himself with the
secret society of super villains seeing
it as his best shot at protecting his
people in condoc In 2005's Action Comics
number 831 Superman once again finds
himself at odds with Black Adam who
himself is trying to prevent Dr psycho
from killing people in Metropolis Black
Adam annoyed that he's been associated
with psycho's crimes engages in a pretty
lengthy battle with Superman the two
appear evenly matched here as they duke
it out across Metropolis but when Black
Adam shows little regard for the
innocent civilians around him Superman
gets even angrier
Heroes don't kill people
well I do after nearly pummeling Black
Adam into orbit Superman is forced to
stop when Black Adam turns his back on
him banking on the fact that he's not
only the Man of Steel but a man of Honor
it's a gamble that pays off the fight
comes to an end and the pair strike a
deal with Dr psycho he will release the
citizens of metropolis from his mind
control if Superman allows him to walk
free reluctantly Superman agrees though
only after Black Adam assures him that
Dr psycho will be punished for his
actions this would be the last battle
between Superman and Black Adam in the
mainstream continuity
after Superman and black Adam's new
Earth tussle various crisis events took
place across the DC continuity changing
the powers Origins and even the
personalities of numerous characters in
The New 52 continuity Black Adam briefly
fought an evil version of Superman from
Another Earth named Ultraman during an
event called Forever Evil this scrap
doesn't end well for Black Adam with
Ultraman crushing his jaw and leaving
him unable to speak the magic word
Shazam though he eventually heals he is
left humiliated by the resounding defeat
after the DC rebirth Rebrand Black Adam
encountered the Man of Steel on several
occasions including briefly in the
Doomsday Clock limited series and in the
endless winter crossover event where he
swore revenge on Superman after the hero
stopped him from killing the frost King
however his frustration with Superman
would be short-lived as the man of steel
would invite Black Adam to turn over a
new leaf and join the Justice League
hoping for some fresh perspectives
Superman thinks that Black Adam joining
the league would be good for everyone
involved it's a bold move that pays
dividends as Black Adam turns to once
again be the mighty Adam
though Black Adam doesn't Battle
Superman all that often in the
mainstream DC Universe there are a few
different alternate realities in which
these two powerhouses face off against
one another in 2020s deceased hope at
World's End a zombie-like anti-life
virus begins infecting people across the
world hoping to contain the virus and
its spread Black Adam begins using
lethal Force against his own citizens in
condoc unfortunately for Adam he gets
infected by the disease at the moment he
goes to invoke the name of Shazam making
Black Adam one of the undead naturally
Black Adam infects his entire nation and
leads them toward global domination in
response the Justice League sends
Superman Martian Manhunter Green Lantern
and Cyborg to stop Black Adam while his
horde of zombies manages to escape
Superman and his team nearly defeat
Black Adam before he recognizes their
tactics and Retreats himself eventually
Superman uses his heat vision to sever
black Adam's vocal cords so he can no
longer use the magic word Shazam it's
brutal but necessary under the
circumstances
though Superman and Shazam rarely share
screen time and animation outside of
shows like Justice League Unlimited and
Young Justice they did share top billing
in a DC animated original where they
fought against Black Adam together that
film is Superman Shazam The Return of
Black Adam which retells the story of
how Billy Batson first gained the powers
of Shazam in it Black Adam returns to
Earth to find the Wizard's new champion
and decides to take the power for
himself when Black Adam shows himself
Superman Works to stop him from killing
young Billy and the two battle across
the Metropolis Skyline until Billy gains
his Captain Marvel powers and helps the
Man of Steel take down his Nemesis for
good this short proves that while
Superman and Black Adam are traditional
adversaries they're certainly an
appetite to associate them with one
another inside DC outside of this short
film Black Adam and his dog Anubis
recently appeared in the final
post-credits scene of DC League of Super
Pets where they encountered Superman and
his dog crypto your own is a hero too
the hero it's basically exactly like a
regular hero except way cooler between
that and the Black Adam movie it seems
like DC is trying hard to ignite a
rivalry between these two on the big
screen
in the Epic cinematic trailer for The
massively multiplayer online game DC
Universe Online the Justice League
battles members of the secret society of
super villains in a shocking turn of
events the society begins to overpower
and kill members of The League after
hearing the cries of his teammates
Superman arrives to fight the society
easily taking down super villain after
super villain in the process one of them
is Black Adam who barely manages to hold
his own against the Man of Steel the
2013 fighting game Injustice Gods Among
Us features Black Adam as a member of
the evil Superman's Global Group regime
which has taken over the planet to keep
it safe as a member of the regime Black
Adam runs various errands for Superman
at least until a good Superman From
Another World arrives and quickly
defeats him in the sequel Injustice 2
Black Adam is a major player working
alongside members of Superman's regime
and Batman's Insurgency to stop Brainiac
from destroying the planet elsewhere the
evil Superman tussled with Black Adam in
the pages of the companion comic book
series to the Injustice Gods Among Us
video game franchise 2.
the DC extended Universe started in 2013
with Zack Snyder's Man of Steel and went
on to have varying levels of success
depending on the project Henry Cavill
made his debut as Superman in that film
and would reprise the role in 2016's
Batman vs Superman dawn of Justice
2017's Justice League and of course
2021's Zack Snyder's Justice League the
director's cut of the critically bashed
team-up movie by far Earth's strongest
protector Superman has battled Alien
Invaders monsters and even Gods from
other Realms making him a formidable
opponent as a founding member of the
Justice League Superman Works alongside
the DC extended universe's most
impressive Heroes but none of them can
match him in terms of power however now
that Black Adam is on the scene there's
a being who can potentially do just that
so I'm locked it up
Superman played once again by Henry
Cavill appears at the end of Black Adam
with hopes of talking to the titular
anti-hero about his presence in the DC
Universe and there's no doubt that this
thread will lead to some interesting
places what is a little strange is that
it seems as though there are no plans
for Black Adam to face his comic book
Nemesis Billy Batson anytime soon with
Superman making Cameo appearances in
both Shazam and Black Adam maybe the Man
of Steel will be the bridge that brings
these classic enemies together on the
big screen whatever the future holds for
the Rivalry between Black Adam and
Superman we're excited to see what comes
next and how these two powerhouses will
interact with each other
foreign
[Music]